JOEL LEWIS: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture, you've been
doing related rates problems.
I've got another
example for you, here.
So this one's a
really tricky one.
So I'm going to give you
some time to work on it.
But I really think you
should try and work
through this one yourself.
It'll be well worth your effort.
So we've got here--
OK, so this is a mouthful.
We've got a 20-foot-long
ladder and it's
leaning against a 12-foot wall.
But it's leaning over the wall.
So 5 feet of the ladder project
over the top of the wall.
And then the bottom
of the ladder
is being pulled away from the
wall at 5 feet per second.
The question is, while
this is going on,
how quickly is the top of
the ladder going downwards?
How quickly is it
approaching the ground?
So why don't you
take a few minutes.
Well, maybe more than
a few for this one.
It took me a while to work
it out the first time.
Take a few minutes, work
this one out, come back,
and we'll see how it went.
All right.
So hopefully you've had
some luck working out
this problem on your own.
Now let's work it out together.
So OK, so this is a sort
of classic, really tricky
related rates problem in that
there's a lot of geometric work
that you have to
do at the beginning
in order to get this right.
And then once you get
the geometry down,
the calculus is basically
totally straightforward.
You know, you compute a
couple of derivatives,
you use the chain
rule once, whatever.
You know.
So OK, so let's start
off by trying and drawing
a careful picture.
And then we'll
have to figure out
what the quantities
that we're interested in
are and the relationships
between them.
So we have here,
here's the ground.
And we have a 12-foot wall.
And we have a 20-foot ladder
leaning against the wall
and extending over it.
So, my ladder.
So here's my ladder.
Here's my wall.
All right.
And this, the bottom
of the ladder here,
is what's getting pulled
away from the wall at 5
units per second.
5 feet per second.
So 5 feet per second is
how fast that's going.
And we're interested--
so while you do that,
you know, the ladder
is changing position.
So the question is, how fast
is the top of the ladder
descending?
So you know, it
might also be moving
in some other
directions, but we're
just interested in how quickly
it's going straight down.
So, OK, so first, let's
talk about the things
that don't change.
So the height of this
wall is not changing.
The wall is staying
put the whole time.
And the length of the
ladder is not changing.
That's staying put, as well.
But what--
OK, so those are the fixed
quantities in this problem.
Basically, everything
else is changing.
So for example, this distance
between the base of the wall
and the base of
the ladder, that's
changing because the
ladder is being pulled away
from the wall.
So we can give that a name.
Let's call that-- that's
a horizontal distance,
so we can call that x, say.
And the height of the top
of the ladder is changing,
so let's draw that in.
That's what we're interested in.
It's the height, so
we can call it y.
And let's see.
What else?
Well OK, the whole ladder
isn't changing in length,
but the amount, but
as this gets pulled,
you know, this top point
is sort of sliding down
towards the wall, the amount
of the ladder that extends
over the wall is changing.
So I guess we could choose.
We could give this
a variable name
or we could give this
part a variable name.
I think I'm going to give the
little one a variable name.
I'll call it d for
distance, I guess.
And, OK.
So if this is d, because the
whole ladder has length 20,
we have that this part, this
segment has length 20 minus d.
OK so, I think that
those quantities
describe all the
possible lengths
of interest in this picture.
So now, OK.
So that's just the
first, the set up.
That's the first thing
that has to happen.
Now after we set up,
we need to figure out
what the relationships between
these different variables are.
Well, let's see.
What have we got?
Well one thing we've
got is that we've
got a right triangle here.
So the wall and the
ground and the ladder.
Those three segments
form a right triangle.
So OK.
So we can apply the
Pythagorean Theorem here.
So that's one
relationship we have,
and that's going to give
us a relationship between x
and well, OK, 20 minus d.
So that'll give us a
relationship between x and d.
So this, so OK, so what does
the Pythagorean Theorem say?
So by the Pythagorean
Theorem, we
have x squared plus-- that's
a 1-- 12 squared is equal
to the quantity 20
minus d squared.
So that's one identity that
we have, identity we have that
relates these three quantities.
And so that's good.
Because we know how
fast x is changing.
And so with this
identity, that means
we can use related rates
to figure out how fast d
is changing, as well.
So that's good.
That'll be a step in
the right direction,
but what we actually need to
know is how fast y is changing.
So-- right?
Because that's what
the question is
asking for-- how quickly
is the top of the ladder
approaching the ground?
So how, what's the
rate of change in y
with respect to time?
So I need another
identity here in order
to figure out what the
relationship with y is
and these other variables.
And there are a couple
of different ways
to go about this.
I think the one that I'm
going to do-- so there
is another right triangle here.
So you could, if you wanted
to name this segment,
as well, then you could
do another right triangle.
But then you'd need
a third relationship
relating this segment to
d or something like that.
So I'm not going
to go that route,
but I'm going to go do
something related to that, which
is that this bigger
right triangle, right,
which has the height of the top
of the ladder from the ground
and the whole length of the
ladder as two of its sides,
and a piece of the ground, so
that bigger right triangle is
similar to this
smaller right triangle.
Right?
I mean, they have,
they're right triangles
and they have the
same base angle there.
So they're similar triangles.
So OK, so by similar
triangles-- now
I have to remember all
my geometry, right?
So the ratio of corresponding
sides are equal,
so in this case, the
ratio of the hypotenuses
is equal to the
ratio of these legs.
And that'll relate-- so
the hypotenuses involve d.
And the vertical legs, well,
one of them is just constant
and one of them involves y.
So that'll set up a
relationship between d and y,
and so then I'll
have x linked to d
and I'll have d linked to y.
And so then we can
use related rates
to figure out what the
relationship between y and x
is and figure out the
thing we're after,
which is the rate
of change in y.
So OK, so I haven't actually
written anything down, yet.
So what is the similar triangle?
So here, let's look
at the hypotenuses.
So the big hypotenuse
has length 20,
and the small hypotenuse
has length 20 minus d.
Good.
So that's the ratio
of the hypotenuses,
and so that has to
be equal to the ratio
of the corresponding legs.
And so the big leg is y,
and the small leg is 12.
OK.
All right, so there's
Pythagorean Theorem.
There's similar triangles.
So we now have the
relationships that we're after,
relating x and y and
d all to each other.
Great.
So now we can do the calculus
part of this problem, right?
So, now we know--
oh, I guess, actually, we
need a few more things.
Take it back.
So now we need the condition.
We're after this at a
particular moment in time,
and at our particular
moment in time--
so I haven't used
this one given yet,
that 5 feet of the wall-- oh,
sorry-- 5 feet of the ladder
projects over the wall.
So OK, so, at our moment,
so at the key moment,
we have that d is equal to 5.
OK, so that means 20
minus d is equal to 15.
What else does that mean?
So that means that
at that moment,
x in this right triangle
is the third leg
in a right triangle with
hypotenuse 15 and one leg 12.
So that's one of
your 3-4-5 triangles,
but blown up a little bit.
So we have at that moment,
that x is equal to 9.
And OK, so at that
moment, to figure out y,
we can use this other
relationship that we have.
So 20 over 15 is
equal to y over 12,
so y is equal to 20
over 15 times 12.
So that's 4 over
3, so that's 16.
So at our key moment
in time, these
are the values that we're
going to end up plugging in.
And also, dx/dt is equal to 5.
x is being increased.
Increased?
Yeah x is, right, so as
the foot gets pulled away,
x is getting bigger.
So x is being increased
at 5 units per second.
All right, so these are all the
things we're going to plug in.
All right, good.
So now we are after
dy/dt at this moment.
And we don't have a
relation-- so, we know dx/dt.
We don't have a direct
relationship between y and x,
but we do have a direct
relationship between y and d.
So if we got dd/dt-- sorry--
dd/dt, then we could get dy/dt,
and because of this
relationship, we can get dd/dt.
All right.
So let's start
off by doing that.
So OK, so this is an identity.
It holds always, so we
can differentiate it.
And we're going to differentiate
it with respect to t.
x and d are functions of t.
So OK.
So differentiating this
identity I get 2x times dx/dt
plus-- well, OK, derivative
of 144 with respect to t
is 0-- is equal to-- I guess
I could expand this out,
but it's easier just to use
the chain rule right away.
So this is equal to
2 times 20 minus d
times the derivative of
20 minus d with respect
to t, which is minus dd/dt.
All right.
I beg the gods of math notation
to forgive me for dd/dt.
But, OK.
So, all right, so now--
this is always true.
And what we want is the value of
dd/dt at our particular moment
in time.
So at our particular moment in
time we have-- well let's see,
so OK, we have x, we have
the dx/dt, and we have d.
So we can just plug
all those things in.
So, at our moment--
let me see how I'm
going to do this.
I'll do it over here.
At our moment-- so 2x is 18
times dx/dt is 5 equals 2 times
20 minus d is 15
times minus dd/dt.
And dd/dt is what we're after.
So OK.
So divide 2 into this is 9.
45 divided by 15 is 3, so
dd/dt is equal to minus 3
at the moment that
we're interested in.
All right.
Great.
So now we have
dd/dt, and so now we
can go back to the
second relationship
we have, the one
that relates d and y,
and we can do the
same thing here.
We can take a derivative,
use the chain rule,
use, and get a relationship
between dy/dt and d and dd/dt.
And then we'll be able to
plug in all these values we
have for our particular moment.
So OK, so I think I'm just going
to differentiate this straight.
There are some simplifications
I could do first,
but it'll work fine if
we just do it straight.
So OK, so I need to
compute the derivative.
This is an identity.
I can take its derivative,
so I differentiate
the left-hand side
with respect to t,
so I get 20 over-- so this
is a minus first power-- so I
get minus 20 over
20 minus d quantity
squared times-- I need the
derivative of the bottom--
is minus dd/dt.
And on the right-hand
side I get dy/dt over 12.
So I have this relationship
between d and y,
I take its
derivative, now I have
a relationship that involves
dy/dt, which is the thing
that I'm after.
So, whew.
So now, I'm back at
this plugging-in stage.
So at our moment in
time, I know what d is,
and I just figured
out what dd/dt
is, so I can just
plug those values in
to figure out what dy/dt is.
So OK, so let's do that.
So at this moment
in time we have-- so
let me just multiply
through by the 12
and that will let us
solve-- so we have dy/dt
is equal to 12 times-- well, so
it's minus 20 over 15 squared,
times minus minus 3.
Times 3.
So this is-- all right.
Arithmetic.
Not my favorite
thing in the world.
So we've got two 3's here.
We're going to end up with
a 5 in the denominator,
and then we've got 4 times minus
4, so that's minus 16 over 5.
So.
All right.
So that's the answer.
Let's remember what we've done.
So minus 16 over 5,
that's a negative number.
Why is it a negative number?
Well, as we pull this, the
bottom of this ladder here,
away from the wall,
the top of the ladder
is going to fall
downwards, it's going
to get closer to the ground.
And y is the vertical
distance between the ground
and the top of the ladder.
So that's shrinking; y
is shrinking and should
have a negative derivative.
OK.
Negative derivative, minus
16 over 5 feet per second.
So it would take, if this
instantaneous rate held up,
which it won't in this
situation-- if it held up
it would take 5 seconds
to get down, so it's not
falling very quickly.
OK.
That seems about right.
Anything else?
I guess we computed that
dd/dt was also negative.
Same thing here.
When you pull this way, this
length is going to shrink,
so d is getting smaller, so
it has negative derivative.
OK.
So at this moment in time,
the top of the ladder
is falling-- the thing we're
interested in-- at exactly
16 over 5 feet per second.
And we're all set.